c'est décourageant mais paul lachat
ulysse blais et la veuve de jean yves
blais le porte-parole du recours
collectif déposé en 1998 il est mort le
3 ou 2012 d'un cancer du poumon
six mois après le début du procès sa
veuve se souvient des derniers moments
le procès devant le juge boilard a ordre
de la cour supérieure du québec a débuté
en mars 2012
il a duré deux ans et demi deux cent
cinquante trois jours d'audience 76
témoins ont été entendus dont jeffrey
white and ce lanceur d'alert américains
qui avaient dénoncé des pratiques des
compagnies de tabac pour maintenir la
dépendance à la nicotine
son histoire a même fait l'objet d'un
long métrage et les rien moi traité
comme un cri d'un des plus gros
problèmes de santé publique de notre
histoire
dans son jugement fleuve rendu en juin
le juge riddle a conclu que l'industrie
du tabac savait depuis les années 50 que
les cigarettes causait le cancer du
poumon les publicités de l'époque
vantait les mérites de la cigarette
oui c'est toujours un plaisir de fumer
la cigarette du maurier il ordonnait
donc aux compagnies de tabac de verser
15 milliards de dollars à 100 1000
québécois victimes du tabac les
compagnies ont rejeté ce verdict et ont
donc porté la cause en appel le 21
novembre 2016 début du procès en cour
d'appel du québec devant cinq juges
en effet tout ce qu'ils m'ont fait c'est
moi c'est dur de me ménage pas parce
qu'on a un projet yves minatchy
malgré ce procès le nombre de fumeurs se
maintient au pays
ils sont 16% au canada 18 % au québec
le tabac tue en moyenne 45 mille
personnes par année au pays
selon la société canadienne du cancer
la décision de la cour d'appel vendredi
mettra un terme à l'un des plus longs
procès au pays
lise blais est fébrile et compte se
battre jusqu'au bout pour son mari je
serai là avec ma galerie d'art peu
importe le jugement il y a de fortes
chances que ce dossier se rendre
jusqu'en cour suprême
alors si vous gagnez ce sera pour lui au
wawel ici catherine kovacs radio-canada
à montréal